how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
mcu and today we have some pretty big
updates about projects happening for
marvel's phase four a little bit diving
into phase five and some possible
new trailers coming today there are a
lot of new projects upcoming that we
have learned a little bit about
including spider-man no way home
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 the
hawkeye series and upcoming echo series
miss marvel and secret invasion so as
you can see
a lot to go over today and with so many
upcoming
marvel projects both big and small
things are starting to get
truly exciting the multiverse is now
real we are in it
the marvel cinematic multiverse as a lot
of people are calling it
and a lot of things are about to go down
so if you want to stay up to date on
everything happening in the mcu be sure
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell
so the first thing we'll start off with
is going to be spiderman no way home
because i know everybody is just
seeking any type of information for this
film out that they could possibly get
and it looks like we could possibly be
seeing mj's parents in spider-man no way
home
either that or it's a possibility that
we could see
miles morales or a slight setup for him
let me explain why
it has been confirmed that actress paula
newsom is going to be in spiderman no
way home
and speculation started to go off right
away that she could be playing the
mother of miles morales
however this speculation kind of shifted
after she responded to a certain comment
on twitter
about mj twitter user spiderman world
posted this on twitter
omg all of this time i've been thinking
paulo newsom could be playing miles
morales mom
but i didn't think about peter maybe
meeting mj's parents finally
and spider-man no way home and paula
newsom actually replied to this tweet
and she replied with a
winky face now this is kind of funny
because is she winking
at the fact that she could be miles
morales mom
or mj's mom because look we already know
that miles morales
exists in the mcu remember spider-man
homecoming remember childish gambino
donald glover playing aaron davis
prowler the uncle of miles morales heck
he even mentioned his nephew
in the movie so miles does exist let's
not forget that we don't need the
multiverse to
bring him into the mcu because he's
already there
so could paula be playing his mom yes
and hopefully she is but
it's probably going to be mj's mom
especially if you consider
everything that's going to be going down
in spiderman no way home
since mj is kind of involved with peter
now her mom would probably be
pretty concerned if she found out that
her daughter's boyfriend
is spider-man and wanted for murder that
would probably be
pretty concerning to a parent however we
do know how marvel is and kind of what
they tell their actors to do
you know throw people off of what
they're actually doing so perhaps maybe
this is misdirect and she is playing
miles's mom
but to not get my hopes up and your
hopes up i'm gonna go ahead and say it's
gonna be mj's mom and if it ends up
being miles i'm gonna be happy
also in spider-man related news but not
necessarily no way home news
it has been confirmed that kingpin is
going to be entering the
mcu specifically it is going to be
vincent dionofrio's
kingpin who will be returning many
different credible sources have been
talking about this online but the real
giveaway was when vincent d'ionofrio
actually started
liking post about him returning as
kingpin and according to people over at
comicbook.com he's not only going to
just
appear in one series but he'll be around
for a little bit
now it's said that he's supposed to come
in hawkeye and actually bleed over into
the echo series
in which kingping obviously has a huge
connection to ekko in the comics but the
fact that vincent is going to return as
kingpin
is great news because a lot of people
thought that they really couldn't recast
him that he was pretty perfect for the
role and i'd have to agree
next we have some new guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 updates from james gunn
himself
now guardians of the galaxy vol 3
supposed to be coming in 2023 but before
that
in december of 2022 we are getting the
guardians of the galaxy christmas
special and for those of you kind of
brushing this off
it's actually going to be quite
important according to james gunn he
recently stated that the guardians of
the galaxy christmas special is going to
be a lot of fun
and it's going to give viewers
everything they need to know before
watching volume
3. so it's kind of a little bit of a
segue into it
and it will probably fill some gaps
between what happened
in thor love and thunder and volume 3.
now as far as the script of guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 james gunn has
reiterated that his script for the movie
has been done for about three years he
hasn't really changed much he said that
what he has changed is very little
and this is great news because that
means we could probably still
expect adam warlock to show up in
guardians of the galaxy
vol 3. that was a really big setup after
volume 2
so if he changed that that would
probably be a
big change and he says that he's only
made small changes so hopefully
him adam warlock is still coming now as
far as upcoming shows
miss marvel and hawkeye are expected to
premiere this year
hawkeye is actually expected to premiere
in november
very close to spider-man no way homes
release in december
so there's a possibility that the two of
them could be connected somehow because
remember what kevin feige said
if you want to keep up to date with the
things happening in the mcu you have to
watch the disney plus
shows and speaking of it has been
confirmed that brie larson's captain
marvel will be appearing in the miss
marvel disney plus series this will be
brie larson's third
mcu appearance as captain marvel and she
will be appearing
in two episodes of miss marvel it's also
expected that she's going to appear in
secret invasion as well we've recently
learned that secret invasion is going to
start filming in mid-august and go
till december which means we'll be
getting a 2022 release date for secret
invasion
also peyton reed the director of ant-man
and the wasp quantum mania has confirmed
that ant-man 3
is now currently filming which means
kang
is coming
this is wild wow
come on now to top off today's news it
looks like something could be going down
today
at 3 p.m pacific time disney plus is
going to be hosting a live event on
twitter today
and during this live stream it's been
speculated that we're going to be
getting
something on the marvel side now this
could be something that we've already
seen or it could be
new footage for marvel's what if or
maybe even something for miss
marvel since miss marvel has been
filming for a long time
they could very well have some teaser
footage that they're ready to show us
and i wouldn't expect anything from the
eternals or shang qi
remember this is about disney plus and
yes black widow did release
simultaneously
and that could be the case for chongqi
and the eternals but they're still
primarily talking about their shows
in which there are a lot of marvel
shows coming up on disney plus but with
what if so close
about two weeks away i'm gonna go ahead
and say that if we get any type of
teaser for anything
it's probably going to be what if oh and
before i forget
i almost forgot in regards to guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 picking up
where it left off at the end of
guardians 2 it looks like this
is still the plan randall emmett the
director of midnight and switchgrass and
a friend of sylvester stallone
mentioned that stallone is still going
to be
in guardians of the galaxy vol 3. that
combined with james gunn stating that
his script has been done for about three
years
i'm pretty convinced that where
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 left off
with all of the ravangers and with adam
warlock
is still where we're going to pick up
from in guardians 3. which is great news
because i know a lot of people have been
wanting to see that
myself included so a ton of news that
happened
this week let me know what you think
about all of this in the comments down
below and let me know what you are
most excited for in terms of future
marvel projects
don't forget to subscribe and like the
video and for live updates you can
always follow me on instagram and
twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof